un amour de vacances et pourquoi pas les
passer avec les célibataires les plus
convoités c'est-à-dire princes et
princesses qu'est ce qui s'est passé
toute la saison il est malin mais sur ce
front qui se casse la gueule à la menace
fatale du bilan folie qu'est ce qui se
passe
mon dieu je voulais monter si mal comme
ça qu'est-ce qui se passe bah c'est le
fauteuil qui bat ça va je suis c'est
bien ça va tu es bien ça va
[Rires]
j'avoue que tu es l'école d'une femme -
présent tenu quatre célibataires garçons
et filles aussi voilà les plus convoités
en flamand qui forme des frais ou et
pourquoi bas ce sont ceux que je vous
conseille donc comment le rencontrer
malgré cet été sur les plages on va
commencer peut-être pas c'est pas le
plus fort tuner un prince danois mais
c'est le plus sexy de la planète golf va
revoir et le nikon à nicolas liautard de
djalma
trois exactement
il ferait pas partie du club mais aussi
les mannequins dans l'ordre de
succession au trône cette phase où
on
suit les bombes si le rappel va dire
c'était moins fortunés de tous donc du
salon ou moins fortunés on va dire que
la couronne danoise n'est pas la plus
fortunée de tout mais il n'est pas à
rien à voir bien les ententes de
montpezat vab deux ans il y aura
beaucoup plus fortunés si tu veux et les
mannequins top modèles défilent
régulièrement comme il ya deux ans vient
de france à mes mannequins ne veut pas
toujours dire beau oui bah on le voit en
2002 il a maintenant 11 ans tu as prince
de 22 ans fortune et mannequin ça va ça
va barder mais les files ou non mais il
fait son temps jenson conseillé d'écrire
lui ou le croisait alors et rendre au
château cas ips château cates qui est la
propriété de la couronne dame a pas mal
c'est vous alors le let a dans le lot
comme si en france
puisque son grand-père le prince henrik
de danemark était français fait
alors le deuxième principe que je vous
propose de rencontrer sur le dur sata il
est vraiment free
séchage et touche à tout il est le petit
fils de la princesse margaret avec la
sauce de la reine elizabeth deux séances
on l'associé de voeux d'elizabeth ii il
est 30e dans l'ordre de succession au
trône britannique et je pense qu il est
tout fait pour huglo dans le fond
puisque nationale et a déjà lui pense
aux conduites man un peu on dirait que m
il est coach sportif à edimbourg et
sachez quand même que sa passion et bien
c'est la ram il a fait de la ramière et
le tour de la grande bretagne comment tu
fais la ram et ça marche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pendant deux jours pour fait le tour de
la grande bretagne mais n'aurait l'arrêt
des groupes ou les antennes mais disons
que des coteaux où il croisé avec la
reine elizabeth ii le coup quand il est
très très proche il fait de grandes
randonnées dans les forêts de balma et
souvent torse nu
très beau gosse suivante je crois
amis je vous propose luis pensser ses
aveux de dallas
j'ai pris un coup et le quatrième fils
de son frère charles à le comte spencer
c'est le futur dixième comte spencer la
fortune familiale est évalué à
seulement six lignes au sol de la 145
145 millions d'euros avec 28 ans il
mesure 1 mètre 90 et b787 kg pour le
coup tu as tout les mensurations de
nom mais c'est vraiment ils apprennent
micro 7 kg
pour commencer enchères 12000
[ __ ] et la presse dit qu'il est gentil
comme williams et a comme harry
condé zakhem des gens qui sont bien nés
comme un oui voilà tu es bon sur des
millionnaires battait jeu ne s'arrête
pas mais face à estelle des gens tu vois
il ya comme une injustice
moa a de quoi être prince à aide à être
bon il ya des travers
le mari desquels
il n'est pas
en train de me trouver suivant famille
royale espagnole on part en espagne ces
indiens
[Applaudissements]
dans les fans à nous mais il avait
refusé certains qui étaient quand même
un peu plus sur ses lacunes ajoute
yves sorbonne est il à bientôt 24 ans
est le fils de l'influent et l'ina et
alors il est grand d'espagne il a reçu
le titre de grand d'espagne donc appelé
le votre excellence
et sachez que si l'espagne avait
continué à ne vouloir que des hommes sur
le trône il faut savoir que cette loi a
été revue et bah il serait l'héritier du
trône puisque le prince felipe n'a que
deux filles en bas avec des signes ici
devant élèves la corrida où le braz et
bien c'est un résidant en espagne à la
villa marie van qui est la grande
propriété de vacances de la famille
espagnole où il participe à la côte mais
c'est chiant pour nous nous tenons sur
une plage tournée content mais si pour
le croiser c'est dans un palais ça avant
d'escalader impôts chaud mais non parce
que la régate de la copa del rey 7 au
bord de la mer c'est une réunion louis a
souvent poulaga de mission
mais on veut tourner en duo avec lady
amelia windsor à alger par les intimes
c'est la nièce de diana
l'a 26 ans et oui c'est pas mal à nier
c'est la petite fille du duc de kent
pardon vous avez qu'est le duc de kent
c'est celui qui est apparu à côté
d'elisabeth 2 au bal grave accident à
l'approbation 4 à 6 ans et bien c'est la
petite fille
bien mais c était avant bizarre elle est
influent ce square le coup et où la
croisée j'ai fait une petite enquête et
bien si vous vous allez à ibiza vous
vous rendez à l'hôtel s'y sentait très
jeune un hôtel qui s'appelle cinq heures
manif je les y ai là encore la très
jolie voix qu'elle est mannequin vieux
de grosse baraque derrière tout ça
j'imagine que l'heure est à la 43e mail
dans l'ordre de ses très jeunes n'ont
pas de vision
alors ça m'a passé fait rien elle est
journaliste pour tatler
ajouté ne sont pas si nous en fout non
là
ça va adresser une olympiade grâce à l
issue de la famille royale
un mot c'est la seule fille du djihad
cheminée serait de graisse on appelle le
djihad qui sont pas d'accord et se dit
ado boys degré t de marie-chantal miller
la fortune est considérable puisque
sachez que très moyennement richard
miller est un peu l'inventeur des
boutiques duty free dans l'entré grecque
qui charmera c'est la seule partie de
tout ce que tu as dit jérôme
richard mille si vous suivez toujours et
le côté le populaire c'est sa mère
et sa fille et influence alors la
suivante que ça fait 1 16-1
ya des savoirs pas en italie
ces actions de clotilde courau vous
voyez le nombre
depuis huit ans absolument elle est
princesse de carignan et marquise dit
vrai c'est ça titulature et a laissé la
première dans une héritière de la
couronne d'italie depuis mille ans mais
même si la question arrivait me brun
devenu n'existe plus on perd son
très beau prince de fées maps brigitte
régulièrement à paris et alors fortune
est là puisque il faut savoir que depuis
des années et mila en conflit qui oppose
emmanuel philibert au gouvernement
italien et quiconque qui concerne une
cassette de bijoux on parle de 6me
diamant et 2009 estimé à plus de 300
millions d'euros emmanuel-philibert est
sur le point de remporter cette bataille
judiciaire
elle se partage entre rome en effet ils
sont toujours aussi belles en 11 jours
oui oui oui ou non non non c'est cela
oui oui et je crois qu'elle josas c'est
un petit wyatt quoi je crois qu'elle
joue au tennis
et en interne une courte et plus proche
de nous très européenne ou le rex en
bras de luxembourg c'est pas la plus
glamour s'attacher l'appellation fil
musique
michelle et moi
j'en ai choisi
de nous la seule fille du grand ducale
et saha 31 ans quand on mène qu'en 2019
le magazine business insider qui aurait
mis une référence estimé la fortune de
la famille grand ducale donc du
luxembourgeois à 3,5 me moyart
tous les jours comme un médiateur en
soirée leur présentation
[Rires]
qu'est ce qu'un principe